hello everyone and welcome to another
incredible game from this year's
European individual Championship it's
the man with the greatest hair in the
Chess World Anton korbo vs former video
World chess champion Jerusalem ponomario
and this game uh is uh is just uh an
absolute Thriller to watch it's hard to
imagine that this is a classical game
played in classical time format uh
because the the positions that you will
see here uh are you know something that
you would expect in in a bullet game uh
but they are and it's uh well it's just
extremely complicated so let's uh dive
straight into it according with the
white pieces opens with Ponte D4 uh with
Knight to F6 C4 with C4 we have Pawn the
E6 uh Knight to F3 and D5 the Queen's
Gambit decline with Knight to C3 and now
Bishop to B4 almost the almost the names
of Indian but not really it's the ragos
in defense we have Queen to A4 check
Knight to C6 and now Ponte resolve and
played before nothing new here Bishop to
D2 and this is where it gets really
really interesting here the standard
move is D captures on C4 because you
don't wanna uh you don't want to allow
white to play Pawn to C5 but that's
exactly what um Ruslan did here uh
usually you play captures captures and
then you play Bishop actor at the D6 but
he went Bishop back to D6 without first
capturing on C4 and now Pawn to C5 by uh
Anton Bishop back to E7 and now Ponta B
for preparing Pawn to B5 and it seems
like uh Ruslan might have mixed up the
move order but it's so early on in the
game that you don't um you don't really
believe this so he definitely prepared
something uh Knight the E4 we have
pawned the B5 and now Knight captures on
D2 and there actually is a game that
reached this exact same position uh it
was played in a game between Raha
Mohammed Fahad and the Mustafa yomas uh
where uh last year was played were nine
captures and D2 was played but here
Anton played King captures on D2 and it
is now as of movie 11 that we have a
completely new game so here at night the
B8 getting the Knight out of Harm's Way
Bishop to D3 nicely developing and pawn
to C6 now we have Rook 8 to B1 and the C
captures on B5 with Bishop captures on
B5 and queen to C7 developing the queen
nicely Rook H to C1 and now Pawn to F6
the white Rook is now also nicely
positioned um uh opposite the queen on
the C file we have Bishop back to D3 now
making room for the Knight on B5 and now
comes Knight to C6 we have Queen to C2
now putting pressure on the H7 Pawn
Ponta F5 and now Knight the B5 attacking
the black queen queen to B8 and now
Queen to C3 we have Pawn to A6 chasing
away the Knight and this is uh what
Anton prepared with this weird Queen to
C3 move he played Knight the D6 he gives
up a pawn and it's very odd because this
is a beautiful pawn bishop captures Pawn
captures Queen captures and now he plays
Rook the B6 and now if you look at the
position it seems like what is white
doing he just gave up a very strong Pawn
uh for what well the problem is uh black
can't really develop the queen side so
unless black figures out how to defend
this Pawn to get the bishop into the
game and how do you even get the bishop
into the game you can't get the Rook
enter game and it's it's just a very big
big handicap for black so here we have
Queen to d8 a very interesting way is
Pawn to F4 because you would really love
opening up your your f file the problem
is Pawn to E4 and now okay it's not all
that much if anything this helps white
it uh open up Anton's light Square
Bishop like this so instead we have
Queen backed the d8 attacking the rook
and now Queen to C5 corable just uh uh
uh keeps up the pressure not allowing uh
Jerusalem to develop his pieces Rook to
F7 now comes Bishop captures on A6
winning back the pawn and the idea is
pretty simple okay you can't capture
because then nothing is defending the
Knight on C6 and if you capture then
Rook captures again nothing will be
defending the Knight on C6 and it's a
very tricky line that isn't uh winning
for wide rending but it's just extremely
complicated and the way you have to play
this with black uh is okay you could
play what uh Ruslan played in the game
which is Rook to C7 but the interesting
way is Pawn to G5 and now Pawn to G4 is
coming and now look at this Ponte A3 so
you can move the bishop and the A3 Pawn
will be defended you don't want to allow
something like Rook captures an A2 check
G4 now Knight back to E1 and Bishop to
D7 this ship characters and B7 attacks
The Rook now comes Rook the A5 attacks
the queen on C5 Rook to B5 defending and
now comes Knight captures on D4 and this
is where everything just explodes it's
still a dead draw but uh it's it's hard
to see why if Rook captures the Knight
the B3 with a monster Royal Fork here
the queen king ended the Rook get forked
so that doesn't work and if you try e
Captain D4 then Rook captures on B5 and
after well the bishop is saying you can
play something like Queen to C7 but then
Rook B2 check and now you can't block
with the Rook because it's a free Queen
so King to E3 but now f for checking the
three Bishop B5 check King to C3 and now
just Rook captures on C7 check uh White
is down a queen and white will get
checkmated very soon so you can do that
so after Bishop captures on A6 Rook the
C7 was played he didn't go for that uh
while the G5 line uh now comes Knight
back to E5 and okay you still can't move
down night now the The Rook will also be
hanging on C7 Queen to H4 putting
pressure on the F2 pawn and not just
King back to E1 by korob saying uh yeah
it's moved 26 I'm just gonna casually uh
Castle artificially on move 26. uh and
here uh the the last attempt for black
to save this game would be Pawn to F4
it's a very strong threat threatening F
captures on E3 because the F2 Pawn would
be pinned we would see something like
Knight back to F3 attacks the queen
queen goes back Bishop goes to D3 and
non-bf captures an E3 with some problems
for white as both A2 and F2 are hanging
now so this would be the way to play
this however after King to E1 uh Mario
played Queen captures on H2 and this is
now a problem uh feel free to pause the
video and try to find the only winning
move for korob while I give you a couple
of seconds
uh so for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on spotting the
idea because it's extremely complicated
the spot why it's even winning and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show it is Queen to D6 an incredible
move and it still looks pretty weird yes
you're attacking The Rook on C7 but why
is it winning well congratulations to
everyone who spotted this because look
at this queen to G1 check not King to D2
allowing Queen captures and F2 but
rather King to E2 and this is now a
problem Queen captures on C1 now comes
Rook captures on C6 the problem is uh
you can't go after the uh the The Rook
if you play Queen captures on C7 then
just Knight captures and D4 with check
opens up a discovery and you will lose
the queen on C7 so instead after Queen
captures on C1 Rook captures on C6 and
now uh if you play B captures and C6
this is just meeting one the Knight
covers the F7 Square so instead we have
Queen to beat you with check King to F3
and now Rook the F7 and here pretty much
anything is winning for corvo you could
just capture with Knight captures and F7
but Coral decides to finish in style he
plays Rook to C7 and there is no move
black can make here it's absolutely
stunning stunning position uh the idea
is of course if you capture then you
don't have a rook to block checks so
Queen d8 will again be Checkmate in the
game Rook captures an A6 was played uh
but now of course it's just a nice
meeting too Rook uh captures on C8 check
was played and he was in this position
on move 32 that Jerusalem ponomario
resigned in the game as there is nothing
more to be done here once you block with
Rook to f8 Rook or queen captures an f8
will be Checkmate so a brilliant game by
Anton corable in round five of the
European individual Championship he goes
up to five out of five after this game
and I've checked before I recorded this
video uh he he had he got a very quick
draw yeah in game six so he's actually
on five and a half out of six by to
doing incredibly well on his way after
becoming the European individual
Champion for 2023 it's still early on
but he he's just crushing it uh so yeah
that's the game hope you guys enjoyed it
really really a a wild one you know
every move was uh was a delight to
present so hope you enjoyed it I would
like to thank Jordan Smith as shadri
Rajan Berry day Lobo and Alejandro
Maldonado revision reptiles YouTube for
a contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing to check up on your
wonderful suggestions and everything
else that happens in the Chess World
thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day